if that's what people are trying to hear
then all right then I'm gonna start
wrapping the bum up again cardi B pops
off on Instagram
oh snap snap snap and shares a steamy
teaser from her new movie hustlers let's
talk about cardies insta rant on
Thursday it all started when Jermaine
Dupri was asked on people now who he
admires in the female rap game right now
it's like strippers rapping and I don't
I don't
as far as rap goes I don't I'm not
getting who is the best rapper I'm
getting like okay you got a story about
you dancing in the club cardi never shy
about speaking her mind clap back saying
this reservoir pump to see my best
friend you know I'm saying and second of
all is because it seemed like that's
what people want to hear let me tell you
something when I did be careful people
were talking mesh in the beginning like
what the [ __ ] if that's what people
aren't trying to hear then all right
then I'm gonna start wrapping a bomb up
guess cardi then shifted the
conversation praising several female
rappers who don't talk about their lady
parts there's a lot of female rappers
they be rapping they ask salt and don't
be talking about they don't be talking
about you know getting down and dirty
and yeah I don't be supporting them so
don't blame that on us when you're not
the one they're supporting dance Ciara
back
Kamiya Rhapsody's there's this girl
called aura Nico we need to put these
girls more in magazines
can you stop putting these girls on your
blog's radio DJs you I need to hear
these girls you need to play their music
on the radio they don't rap about a BJJ
they don't rap about sucking
and they don't pass weapons a lot of
people be thinking like it's supposed to
be like a caddy thing and it just feels
good like when other women show love to
each other and they don't know how much
like that means to me though like that
that means like yo you know what one day
you need a kidney I might give you mine
and I barely drink so mines might be
good sanika for people not only is the
press rapper crushing the music game
she's also a movie star too
the 26 year old is making her big screen
debut alongside Jennifer Lopez in
hustlers sharing this steamy teaser to
her instagram thursday parties first
interview about hustlers was with ET
here's what she told us about landing
the gig because I had to be in this
movie like this movie is something that
I could relate it's something that is
like all the actress in the in the movie
I could sell them right no no no this is
how it goes
hmm because you know like the club
they're the club that the movie is based
on like that's the type of clubs that I
work not the first type of clubs that I
worked in how is it working with JLo in
this capacity filming she's just so
caring I cuz I do you need this do you
need that like what do you need so you
want this